rob is honestly the best dad he reminds
me so much of my dad and how attentive
and fun
and loving he is with her rob kardashian
is in a great place
now we are upon our 20th season and
still have so much more of our journey
to share
and as keeping up with the kardashians
enters its final season
et has learned the family's baby brother
quote looks good and
seems happy you know he's such a good
man and such a sweet heart
and he's got a good fine spirit and a
lot of faith
so i put my money on rob we've watched
rob's weight loss journey play out
across the hit reality series
with rob's mom and sisters expressing
frequent concern about his health in
recent years
this is life-threatening at this point
you could only sustain this level of
being unhealthy for so long
now a source told us rob's on the right
track to a healthier lifestyle
opting for a slow and steady journey and
has rejected quick fix
paths like crash dieting the source said
quote
after his daughter was born he committed
to taking better care of his health so
he could have the energy to keep up with
her
and the benefits of that are visible he
looks good and seems happy
the source added that we still won't see
rob shifting back into the public eye
anytime soon
and spending time with his four-year-old
daughter dream continues to be his
priority
i mean it's so exciting you know it's a
really exciting time for him
he's he's really just such a good good
person
the new details follow sister kim's
birthday tribute for rob on wednesday
posting this pic of her smiling brother
kim wrote quote
we've made so many amazing memories this
year that will fill my heart for a
lifetime
adding quote the way our daughters are
besties warms my heart
so much i love you more than anything
and i'm always here for you
eatie chatted with caitlyn jenner last
year where she said rob's journey on
keeping up with the kardashians hasn't
always been easy
but he now seems to be in a good place
how's rob doing do you think we'll see
him on the show more near the end
uh i hope so rob was an integral part of
the show
um uh he's kind of stayed out of the
limelight for the last uh
few years which is fine that's his own
prerogative
you know do what he wants to do um yeah
i hope
during this we're still shooting i think
until like november
uh the final season um yeah i hope
people actually the times i have seen
him and i haven't seen him a lot
of the times i have seen him uh he's
been doing much better
you know and uh i'm happy for him yeah
it's
it's it is the i mean we i know this is
your family but
we're all attached to you guys we the
fans want you to do amazingly and and so
that's good to hear
no i don't i don't think you have to
worry about the family
these are highly motivated men women
they're going to be just fine